[Music]
so a lot of comedians will come out here
and they'll talk about their pride or
their genitals I don't have either of
these things so what I'd like to do is
talk to you about something I love very
much dinosaurs all right I'm glad you
approve because I genuinely want to know
what do you guys think is the best
dinosaur pterodactyl is a winged reptile
not a real dinosaur well I'll get to you
stegasaurus I get it it's a peaceful
herbivore and unique features bony
plates on its back spiky tail the
dumbest thing ever to walk the planet
there's bigger than an elephant it had a
brain the size of a walnut this is
absolutely true it had a second brain in
its stomach to control its tail I had an
ass brain you can't be the best dinosaur
the social obstacle like that what else
well what a rap which Raptor
Velociraptor is the Tonya Harding of the
dinosaur okay because there's an actual
conversation when Jurassic Park got made
where Steven Spielberg sat down Michael
Crichton's like okay really
there's Paul velociraptors but those
things are too small we'll make him look
like the already beloved dinosaur
Diamond Mick is he was super popular I
had an action figure at everything at
the early eighties tights got all
screwed up because he put him in the
movie but that's not what they look like
they evolve din the case they were this
big there's little garbage predators
they weren't scavengers if you
encountered one in the wild it wouldn't
be like it wasn't the movie where his
buddy distracts you and he sneaks up
behind you and unfurls your entrails and
you're like clever
if you encountered one in the wild this
might be like oh hey that's it what else
t-rex I get it it's a big carnivore or
whatever but those poor kids you can't
open a fruit cup what else well what
stereotypes is a fake dinosaur do you
even read boiling boiling dotnet it's a
juvenile Torosaurus what else source oh
god whatever in greek it means different
lizards see a coachella later whatever
what Brachiosaurus is a throat infection
what Barney I have two children okay and
I thought okay we'll try Barney this one
time I put it on it was a tooth brushing
episode but they had to mime it I didn't
have a toothbrush so Barney's sitting in
the corner like a big old creep a bunch
of little kids are going out now what do
you got what you got come on
brontosaurus is another fake dinosaur
look I get it I get book but someone
stole a skull from a camera source and
they put it on an incomplete Apatosaurus
scale in the hoodwinked us for 130 years
we all fell in love watch Len before
time 1 through 13 on Netflix but our
dream of you know going on an adventure
to the volcano has been - what it's
coming out in theaters soon you'll get
your wish it's Japanese for whale
gorillas though so I don't know if that
really qualifies he bought this one time
gorillas went swimming and something
happened that let's all try to forget
what the gorillas did to that whale
spinosaurus is the biggest carnivore of
all time okay biggest badass ever walk
the planet right that should be enough
right but he's got a big freaking sail
like a decorative sail is like what do
you have that for you drive a Porsche
you Baldy how small is your dick midlife
crisis
let's talk please you source green
reptile not a real dinosaur what else
truckasaurus character on The Simpsons
good job better than what Michael Bay's
coming out with in a couple of days or
whatever Oh best dinosaur everybody is
ankylosaurus true his name means the
fused lizard yeah just completely
covered in armor thirty predators could
attack him at once just kneel down take
a nap dream of a peaceful Lagoon filled
with a single malt liquor and cupcakes
nobody could throw him in a dumpster and
steal with lunch money he's not really
the best science because any wakes up
and all the Predators gnawing on their
teeth have drawn a little dick on his
foreheads
you guys been awesome thank you so much
[Music]